so I want to discuss how high blood
sugar has the potential of destroying
your organs and exactly what you should
do about it okay
it's called gluco toxicity the toxicity
of glucose which is sugar so there's a
couple things that happen number one you
get a massive oxidation effect oxidation
is similar to rust on your car okay so
you're getting this breakdown of this
material this can happen in the arteries
and your brain and your nerves and then
what happens your body starts healing it
with proteins calcium cholesterol as a
plaque okay so you start getting
plaquing that's the band-aid that
happens after oxidation and by the way
diabetics that consume more antioxidants
from real food can lower the affect of
this okay then we have glycation what is
that glycation is the effect of heating
up and combining glucose with the
protein for example if you were to eat
barbecued ribs for example you would get
glycation glycation has effect of
altering your proteins in the body and
making them unusable and creating a lot
of damage throughout the tissues and
this can happen anywhere in the body but
there are four main organs that are
affected when you have high sugar number
one is the kidney sugar is very damaging
to the kidney eventually the person ends
up on dialysis because it will literally
destroy the kidney when you have glucose
in the urine for example because you
have so much sugar coming out your body
is trying to get rid of it as a toxic
material but all that glucose is
basically destroying the the filter the
kidney is the filter that filters blood
and you ends up as urine and then you
can't filter anymore and then you
actually need
Dallas's okay number two the eyes number
one it'll affect the tiny blood vessels
in the back of the eye that feed the
retina okay which is a nerve that goes
right into your brain so the retina it
has optical tissue and it's an extension
of your brain sticking out there and
there's all these little blood vessels
that it needs to feed that nerve tissue
well high sugar destroys the blood
vessels which then destroy the nerves
and that's why the end product
having diabetes you end up going blind
okay so it affects the retina it affects
the pressure in the eye is glaucoma it
affects the lens as cataracts and maybe
a personal experience when your blood
sugars are even low because the insulin
is high pushing them down sometimes like
you're blurry you can't see as well next
one is the vascular system okay I'm
talking about the blood vessels to the
heart to other parts of the tissue the
vascular system becomes stiff and you
get oxidation within the wall of the
arteries and that's where you see the
plaque that's where you see the clots
that form that can eventually turn into
a stroke but it's the gluco toxicity
that destroys the vascular system and
this is why diabetics end up with so
many heart problems so we have the
effect of the arteries directly we have
the muscle and we also have the
electrical system of the heart so they
have arrhythmias okay next one is the
nerves okay and the brains I'm
considering this as one but the nerves
are affected primarily the blood vessels
or the capillaries that feed the nerves
okay starting off in the peripheral
nerves and your fingertips and your toes
okay on the bottom of the feet though
you'll start feeling tingling numbness
burning maybe just pain and then just
complete you can't feel that anymore
what's happening is you're destroying
the nerves the remedy for that is
vitamin b1 in the form of a fat-soluble
B one it's called been thought to mean
if you have peripheral neuropathy if you
take that you can reverse that effect
and the reason for that is that we're
dealing with oxidation and vitamin b1 is
like an antioxidant so it can protect
the complications from the high sugar it
can affect the autonomic nervous system
and create a condition called
gastroparesis which is basically you eat
food and it doesn't digest that fast
it's very slow going through the
digestive tract and also the valves on
top of the stomach and even the bottom
of the stomach is controlled by the
autonomic nervous system okay that's
part of the nervous system that can get
destroyed then we have this thing called
the brain gets destroyed the vascular
system that goes in the brain
the oxygen shuts down your brain
actually shrinks when you have high
sugar you destroy the neurons it's
called diabetes type 3 and then there
goes the memory there goes the learning
there goes the cognition but it's really
the toxic the effect of this glucose
that's actually starts the whole cycle
all right now you have diabetes right
okay well you just don't wake up one day
and get diabetes you have pre-diabetes
before that and a pre-diabetes you have
roughly fasting sugar is between 100 and
125 okay and then when it gets above
that 126 or greater on two different
tests you're considered a diabetic okay
so diabetes is too much sugar or it's
hyperglycemia all right so then you take
medication the question you have to ask
yourself is what is the medication doing
with that high sugar is it making it
evaporate now it's cramming it from the
blood into some other place okay so it's
gonna be storing and as fat around the
organs so really we're just taking one
problem and putting the problem
somewhere else it doesn't solve any
problem this is why you have to keep
taking the medication over and over and
over again but what happens before the
pre-diabetes that's the big question
okay because sometimes when you go your
doctor they'll test your sugars and they
say well you're pre-diabetic you might
want to watch your weight right go to a
dietician and then we'll check you in
six months
okay come back six months later it might
be fine good come back in the year come
back later and OH yep you're officially
diabetic we're gonna put you on
medication okay but this whole thing can
be prevented because there's something
that occurs before even the pre-diabetes
okay because it takes like 10 years for
this to happen there's high insulin okay
hyperinsulinemia that's what it's called
they never test your fasting insulin
only the fasting glucose big huge
mistake I want to show you something
this is very interesting
I'll put this article down below a high
fasting plasma insulin concentration
basically high blood fasting insulin
predicts type 2 diabetes independent of
insulin resistance evidence for a
pathogenic role in relative
hyperinsulinemia okay what does all that
mean it means that high insulin can
predict diabetes okay in order to
prevent diabetes you need to know what
happens before diabetes okay all right
so what do we do next okay well we go to
the expert we go to Google okay dr.
Google and we type in hyperinsulinemia
and on a wiki page you'll see some data
on this right here okay and I'm gonna go
directly down to the causes and this is
what they said four things I'm glad they
narrowed it down neoplasm that's a tumor
pancreatic cancer all right
polycystic ovarian syndrome and trans
fats okay now what are they missing a
high carbohydrate diet okay because
insulin responds to glucose all right
that's what it does what happens you eat
a high carbohydrate diet insulin gets
triggered and it pushes the blood sugars
down that's the mechanism so the high
carbohydrate diet is what's really
behind this but they don't mention it
anytime you try to solve a problem and
you're operating off of missing
information especially something like
that you are not going to be able to
solve this problem high insulin comes
before hyperglycemia so what happens do
you have high sugar okay the body's
gonna then start protecting the cells by
creating something called insulin
resistance the high insulin is keeping
the sugar in check for many years you're
having symptoms though because there's a
lot of problems with high insulin just
as many as high sugar okay like frequent
urination thirst blurred vision belly
fat fatigue forgetfulness inflammatory
conditions and the list goes on and on
and on and on right
so then you develop insulin resistance
sooner or later and now what happens
your insulin goes down a little bit in
the blood okay it's going up in other
parts of the tissue to compensate but in
the blood it goes down and then the
sugar starts going up because you don't
have enough insulin to push it down okay
and this gets worse and worse to the
point where you start having this higher
level of sugar and realize in the
beginning of diabetes type 2 we not only
have high sugar but we also have high
insulin and so medically their goal is
to lower the blood sugar but they're not
focused on the insulin because that
would mean acknowledging that high
carbohydrate diets are behind this but
that's just one huge connection they
don't want to validate okay they don't
want to acknowledge high carb causes
high insulin okay there is a tremendous
amount of damage in the body well before
you get diabetes
okay there's oxidation and the arteries
there's things brewing there's all sorts
of things happening all right so now
what is the solution very simple go to
the experts okay go to Google type in
the best diet for diabetes and just take
what the first thing that shows up okay
that's from Hopkins University for yours
people diabetes were warned to avoid
sweets but what research understands I
just love that when they use that when
research but they don't tell us what
research research understands about
diabetes nutrition has changed total
carbohydrates are what counts it was
once assumed that honey candy and other
sweets would raise blood sugar levels
faster and higher than would fruits
vegetables and starchy foods such as
potatoes pasta and whole-grain bread but
this isn't true as long as the sweets
are eaten with a meal and balanced with
other foods in your meal wow I didn't
know that man I could I could have my
cake and eat it too now great although
different types of carbohydrates affect
your blood Sugar's differently it's the
total amount of carbohydrates that
really matter so guys it doesn't really
matter if you do white sugar candy
or fruit or grain it's all about
carbohydrates it doesn't matter anymore
that based on you research how fast that
these foods spike your blood Sugar's so
ignore the glycemic index okay have your
cake and eat it too
sweets count as carbohydrates in your
meal the trick is substituting small
portions of sweets for other
carbohydrates such as bread tortillas
rice crackers cereal fruit juice milk
yogurt and potatoes in your meals all
right so now that you know that just
realize I have a very dry sense of humor
I'm being very sarcastic this is not the
correct information I put a link down
below if you're new to my channel of how
to do healthy keto and intermittent
fasting you need to go on a low
carbohydrate diet but you also have to
be aware of the toxicity of glucose to
various tissues of your body and thank
you so much for watching if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos